well I max you know it's not just the
two in the back between the back or
discrete full range speakers so right
then and there you have this great sound
coming out of both sides and it's
discrete so it's a little bit more sort
of focused I guess with IMAX you get
really discrete sort of left left
surround and right surround I liked it
because it's sort of you kind of caught
more sort of like vocal call-outs or the
announcer calling out the chants just
seemed a little bit more rich in
conjunction with that the full range
front wall of IMAX plus the way they
base management happens in that format
just allowed it to be just such a nice
warm full fuzzy sort of sound it just
sounded this movie just sounded really
really great in IMAX when I go and see
this movie I'm planning to seat in the
IMAX theatre and I think for the very
reason that I like the low end the way
you've got full range speakers and you
get to feel that size in a way that I
don't think is a movie goer I've ever
felt before or I've never felt it better
than an IMAX experience I like the size
of the screen that's cool but it's
really to me it's the fullness and the
thickness of the track in the low end
that makes it much more powerful much
more impressive